Okay.
Hey, what's going on?
It's Bill Burr and It's time for the
Monday morning podcast for my gay Monday,
July 25th, 2016 what's going on?
How? What's going on? Um,
the final Monday in July
of 2016 and a old freckles.
Ol Billy red beard. Oh,
fucking belly fat face. Fucking
trying to get the weight off. Can,
I'm trying to get the weight off.
Working out during the day, eating great,
having a beer at night, fucking
lose everything that he worked for.
It's fucking ridiculous. It's ridiculous
what one beer does. And I just,
I gotta do it.
I got a bunch of beers left over from
the fucking 4th of July that taken up all
this space in my fridge and I'm
not going to throw him out. I mean,
there's children that work in the
Budweiser factory that fucking, you know,
okay.
They sleep on piles of Hay, right?
They pay him 29 cents a month.
I don't know if that's
true. Maybe it's hops.
I don't know what they sleep on now.
There's no people. There's no children.
There's no children working at
Budweiser. That's bad paint, man.
It wouldn't invest in Budweiser. There
was children there under just go, go.
Give me a couple of birdwatchers.
We had protection issues.
Um, my wife's on steroids. What Marie?
He blew out his shoulder.
Mike [inaudible].
Toshi at human growth hormone. Thrasher,
I'm going to show you about that
before. Put my balls on somebody's head.
I'm sorry. I believe in
anonym in a great mood. Um,
yeah, so I've got these fucking, I
got all these bears in my fridge.
What am I gonna what am I, what the
fuck am I supposed to do with them?
I can't throw them out. I got Boddingtons,
I got some millis so I just
have like one a night, right?
And then I have a home pour of
fucking whiskey. That's all she wrote.
That's all she wrote. I barely
even get buzzed off of that too.
When I wake up the next day
and I f I just feel like shit.
I don't know why I keep doing
it. It's a habit I have to break.
I am a w I am a one and
a half drink alcoholic.
I have to have one and a half drinks
and get a little buzzed every night.
I want to go to a fucking AA meeting and
say like, that's my problem. You know,
I'll never forget when I started going
off the rails when I, uh, I would have,
I'd have one m mellow
light tall in a can. And,
uh, then I'd have a home
pour of a whiskey and a,
of course after I finished that,
I would just stop and I'd go to sleep
and the next day I'd wake up and I'd be
totally functional and I'd
go to work. But I, you know,
I'd definitely be a little
grouchy. And, uh, that's my story.
Yeah.
Okay. Thank you for sharing.
Next guy comes up.
My uncle raped me with a
12 pack when I was five.
Right. They'd throw me out of
there. They'd be walking up,
put down him donuts.
I don't know why they all have
southern accents in my world.
Everyone in AA is from the south.
You know why they never got over the war.
They're still fighting it down there.
South's going to rise again and do what?
You're gonna succeed from the Union.
You're going to get old stonewall
Jackson, junior, junior, junior, Julia,
to come back and take over for you.
You know what I say to that? I say,
good luck dye. Say Good
fucking, you know, do it.
Just know this.
You can't have Florida and if you
can't have Florida and you can't go to
California, where are you
going to take your kids?
Huh?
Well, they say I,
you know when they did fucking sitting
there watching your confederate TV,
right?
And it's a small world comes on,
which is even more apropos,
whatever the fuck you say it because
you just like nine fucking states down
there. Whatever the hell you are,
right? It's a small world after all.
And they're like, you want it? What
do they call fathers down in a,
what are the, what do they
call did it? The GM dad. Oh,
I want to go to Disney world. You can't
because you seceded from the union.
You can't go to Disney land and
you can't go to his fucking world.
You know what? You can go Talladega.
You can go see the Winston Cup series.
They got a water slide out there.
I don't think they do.
They've got a bunch of adults.
Skip it around and fucking outfits
that scare children. They do not.
So let me tell you something fucking
there. Mason diction, Mason and Dixon.
Why don't you think twice?
Think about everything you're going to
lose out on a few seceded from the Union,
Huh? No more Disneyland.
No More Disney world
sea worlds down there.
You don't get to see those fucking
fish that don't want to be there. Yeah,
I love that. People think like fish,
like don't give a fuck that
they're in the tank. You know?
Just because they don't have an ability
to speak to us that therefore that means
they have to have fine with it.
We treat fish like immigrants. You know
the fish is fucking looking at you.
You just like right English. You
got a problem with that tank.
Spit it out. Fucking sit
there staring at me. Yeah,
I was on the side of you fucking
scaly head. Be happy I didn't eat you.
You go get me one more time.
I'll cut your fucking head off.
I'll roll you into some flower with an
egg wash and deep fry you motherfucker.
And I'll make your friends watch.
Okay.
Sit there and fucking stare at me like
I work for you. I don't work for you.
Who here is in a tank? I try.
I didn't so I didn't think so. Um,
anyways, um, Bill, why you show off
the fucking walls today? You know why?
Because I,
we wrapped at least the script writing
part of season two of f is for family,
which means I get to go back to being a
fucking 14 year old who has no fucking
job, no responsibilities, no nothing,
just a bunch of beers in my fridge
that I'm slowly going to kill.
I'll do the elliptical in the morning
and then I give it all back with the can
of beer and that's what I do right?
While I fucking wear out my joints.
That's all I'm really doing right now.
I'm just maintaining. Um,
isn't that what a lot of people in this
digital age, you're just trying to do?
Aren't they just trying to maintain,
just trying to keep their heads above
water in this time of change and robots.
Um, if they fucking does the
election, has that happened yet?
Jesus fucking, he ain't go near the
Goddamn TV. Everybody's so fucking scared.
Oh, it's going to happen.
Nothing is going to continue
on the way it's supposed to go.
And whether the fucking comb-over
or the clam gets in the house,
it's going to go in the direction
that the money wants it to go into.
And if it doesn't, okay,
they're going to Dallas.
Right. And then not
going to be in a Tesla.
They're going to fucking roll out that
63 fucking stretch Lincoln convertible.
That's right. Now you're gonna get
the old right there, Fred to there.
Fucking Jesus Christ, the two
of them. You know what I mean?
Their heads. You know what?
If I was in secret service,
there would be a head size that
you could not be above, you know,
or, or else the president would have
to sign a waiver. Just like, you know,
both of them, Hillary and
fucking in Trump, they have,
they have like,
like if you could make sliders
out of Ted Kennedy's head,
that's what the fuck they have.
That is the most amazing
thing about Ted Kennedy.
He had the biggest fucking
head out of all of them and he,
nobody ever took them out. You know,
you would think that that
fucking guy out of all of them,
they all had big
squashes, right. You know,
it's all good looking men do, right?
You've got to have a big head,
big stupid head with this squared jaw
that look in your eye like everything's
going to be okay. The kind of
thing that make women go, oh,
he could pay for all my stuff. Right.
One of those heads, well, what's his face?
Ted Kennedy was at of his
time, no pun intended, right?
If you want to know how
fat people were gonna get,
if you want to know how big
sodas we're going to get,
if you want to know how
fucking ridiculous, you know,
mcmansions and all this shit and all this
stuff that we were going to by the age
of consumerism, right? If you were
back in the 1950s trying to guess,
you had to wage you, which
way is it going to go?
Are we going to go back to living
on dirt floors and log cabins?
Are we going to have
kegerators and Fucking, uh,
chocolate fountains in our houses?
All you had to do is look at Ted
Kennedy said it'd be like, there it is.
That right there. That's an omen.
[inaudible]
you know the interesting thing
about Ted Kennedy's had a,
it was in his entire time he was
alive. It was never backlit ever.
People tried, they just was
never enough light. You know,
there's not even a picture of him
like blocking out the fucking, like,
not even the sun could reach around
either side. It just became night.
You walked outside. Hey, I'm saying
he had a big head. You know, um,
I've got a big head. I got a big kid. I do
literally and figuratively.
I get a giant head.
I got a fucking ego and a half
because I got the whole week off.
And what am I going to do?
I'm going to rest up getting
ready for my European tour,
like the red fucking
headed whore than I am.
And I'm gonna fucking Tuesday night I'm
going to be at the Steve Allen Theater
on Hollywood Boulevard,
the boulevard of dreams.
Um, I'm going to be there and, uh,
just basically saying my shit. So,
you know, I just, I'll need to do is
just fucking say it a few times, right?
Just moderate to myself. Walk
around the block, talk to myself,
hands in my pocket, vigorously scratching
the side of my ball sack. Right.
Having the cops come by, having them
pull over, asking me what I'm doing.
Do I live around here? Are you a vagrant?
I'm sorry. Did you guys see Rudy
Giuliani speech about the police? Man.
That was one of the funniest fucking
things I've ever seen in my life.
The way he was trying to get
that crowd going. You know?
That's [inaudible]
all right. I wanted him to keep going.
You know, he just basically distract,
describe police officers jobs,
but I wanted him to keep
going and I wanted him to, to,
to portray how wealthy he is and,
and the influential friends that he
has. You know, they come to house,
they say you're under arrest, but you
have your lawyer made up in the driveway.
They say Rodeo turned himself.
The charges go away.
I wanted, I wanted him to go that far
because here's the deal. You know,
the way the police would be paid
right now is fucking ridiculous.
It's the same way, you
know, if one comic sucks,
then every fucking comic out there
has a lampshade on the fucking head.
You know what I mean?
There's definitely some terrible
people that are police officers,
but that doesn't mean that they're
all bad. Okay? Now, Rudy Giuliani,
you can't fucking stand there where you
exist in society with your skin color
and think that you can accurately
describe police officers. You know,
and you need somebody a
little more mid range.
Well maybe it's good that he said that.
Okay, now we got the high end right.
Black people fucking said their end
and then you just need somebody in the
middle now. He still can't do it. You
still can't do it because of racism.
You got to try to balance the whole
fucking thing out. Um, I dunno. Hold on.
Say Yeah, you think, you
know, it'd be great with the,
with the fucking cell phone cameras
and then the cops filled themselves.
What would be great is if
somebody fucked up as a cop,
if they actually got fired,
if they actually fucking were
punished and went to jail,
they actually murdered somebody. Not like,
you know, one or two or three people.
If they'd actually just started doing
that. I don't know. I don't know.
I don't know if there's any fucking
solution to it. You know what I mean?
It's a hell of a fucking job to have
when you've got to walk up to a fucking
car, not knowing if you're
going to get shot or not.
That would make me a little
edgy. You know what I mean?
And I think a lot of cons can sit in
there fucking led living room perfect when
they're perfectly safe, being like,
oh, you know what I wouldn't do?
This is what I would've done. Right?
Like when you watch your
fucking quarterback throws
an interception and then you
say, oh, what had dumped it
off to the tight end? Oh,
is that what [inaudible] that's what
you would've done on your fucking couch.
[inaudible] I think it's an impossible
job. And I also think that's a,
there's an element to that
job that fucking statistics
psychopaths are attracted
to bouncers and all those things.
There's a lot of people that just want
to beat the shit out of people that go
for that job. Then there's
other ones that go there.
They have their heart in the
right fucking place, you know?
But they don't really make the
news, you know what I mean?
It's kind of like comics. Like
every night we tell jokes,
nobody gets offended and then one cop
gets fucking offended and then all of a
sudden, is that what it's like
bill? Somebody getting unarmed,
somebody unarmed getting murdered is
like somebody getting in trouble for
Caitlyn Jenner joke. GI Bill. Thanks
for fucking explaining that one. Dow.
Fuck you. It's my podcast.
Okay. I choose not to read.
I choose not to be informed.
That's my choice. Okay.
I'm like one of those feminists,
you know when they fucking
start yelling about that. Oh,
tell me what they do with my body. Right.
Don't tell me what to do
with my podcast. All right.
No more podcasts shaming.
Oh Shit. I had the fucking greatest
set I've had in fucking months.
Saturday night at the comedy
store in the main room,
there was this chunk of material
I've been trying to work out.
I finally set it in a row the
right way and then I came home.
I was so confident of it. I played
it for my wife and even she,
and that's the deal. When you try
something new, this is, this is,
this is the litmus test. And I
mean, know what the fuck that means.
I don't even know if I'm saying
it right. Litmus Lat, Miss Modal,
right. My fucking test is I plan,
play it for the lovely Nia.
And if she fucking left,
you can make your fucking wife get
behind the new shit that you're doing.
Then you know you're onto something.
You know, because in general,
what they do when they first meet you,
they are like, oh my God, you're amazing.
Oh they just fucking pump you up,
right? So you start going like, whoa,
she's really cool man. Right?
And then once they get you,
okay,
once you fucking in the relationship,
once you give him the
ring and you get married,
then they fucking just grabbed the reigns
and shot. You ain't going back. Whoa.
Wow. Right.
They start yakking the fuck
back now cause they're jerks.
It's just out of fear.
Hmm.
He's going to do something new.
He's gonna find something new.
He's going to find somebody new.
That's what they do. Unlike guys,
everybody knows that men are
totally secure with who they are.
Okay?
I'm just doing this right now for any
guy who's listening to this podcast next
to a woman just to listen
to her going, oh my God,
how could you Ms. Guy such an idiot?
Let me tell you something lady.
All right. And don't look at him
right now cause he's not saying this.
I'm talking to you sweetheart. In the
background, shaking your fucking head.
It's your man who's gonna die
before you let him have his labs.
Okay? What you feel right fucking now is
what a man feels when he comes home and
you're walking, you're watching those
botox squawk and fucking whores.
Okay?
Doing the recap of their fucking season
with that Andy Cohen or whatever his
name is, that fucking
genius. He's like bs.
Like the Gay Byron Allen.
You know where they just found
a show where there was no shelf.
Everybody was like this no show here.
Yeah,
and the genius of that guy
to be like, yes there is.
Yeah,
it's not enough.
Did you got a bunch of screaming hordes
yelling at each other that someone's
going to sit down and watch
it every fucking night.
The fact that he then does
the recap, it just sits there.
You don't have to write anything
new. They do it for you.
He just sits there in effortlessly
host the show. He's a master.
Okay.
He just sits, yes. Is this
fucking setlist like a comic?
But all it is is to get these women
yelling at each other and he just,
he just, just watch the
brilliance of that man.
He just fucking sits there and if it's,
if it's fucking Samarin he turns
up the heat, you know, you know,
in episode four, Kathy, she,
she had some choice words in the moment.
That's all he has to say. Oh my God.
When she called me a fucking con and then
she goes and he just fucking lays back
like Ali. Right. And when he
was fighting George Foreman.
And he just lets these women start fucking
punching each other out and they run
off set and he sits there and this
is the brilliance of this man,
is he sits there and he
actually has a look on his face.
Like he truly gives a fuck.
Like he actually gives a shit about these
people. He's just sitting here going,
that's a great TV. And we go,
that just sold some toothpaste
and he's just fucking raking it.
And look at the guy, he
looks like 1 million bucks.
A lot of people don't know this about
that man. He's 83 fucking years old.
You know, everybody
talking about Dick Clark,
how great he looked right
to the fucking end. Yeah.
Well close to the end that I should've
said that, but fucking, you know,
whatever. We all go out
like that. Right. But um,
he's fucking 83 a lot of people don't
know that. You think that guy was like,
you know, like whatever. What,
37 I have no fucking idea.
Yeah.
There's gotta be people hosting real
shit that's fucking difficult going.
Why the fuck didn't I just do that?
Yeah.
What he is is he's doing a
sophisticated Jerry Springer. You know,
everybody's sitting down, there's no
punches thrown. They scream and yell.
They cross their legs. This is the one
thing I'll say about the real housewives.
They're fucking legs are
incredible. It's fucking amazing.
Their legs are like fucking 22
year olds, their fucking faces.
Whoo. You know, Jesus Christ,
and I got a lot of fucking nerve saying
this. Considering the way I look,
considering the way I traveled the world,
looking like an albino balding
Hellboy minus the working out.
Right.
I look like the thing. If it was skinny
and didn't have that skin disease,
you know what I mean? But yet could not
go out in the sun. That's what I am.
I'm a middleweight thing minus whatever.
What's it may not have come on.
Come on. Comic cons. You know
what he's made out of, you know,
he turned into that. Was it
another accident in a lab? Huh?
Did he come here from another planet and
then get bit by a spider and then got
blinded by some shit.
Now he's a fast aunt living
in somebody's fucking head,
you know, driving a jet
ski down to Middle Earth.
Jesus Christ. Yes.
When you think just when you fucking
think that the real housewives is the
dumbest fucking thing
you're ever gonna Watch,
they come out with another
stupid fucking superhero movie.
Jesus fucking Christ. Can Somebody
get the gist collectively?
Get these nerds, some hookers.
You know, why don't they go away?
What are the kids go on now? It tastes,
what does that, what does that fucking,
you know, it's one of those apps,
whatever the fucking is, it's not,
is it Tinder? One of them is like the
Horry and then the other one's like, Ooh,
you know, I like [inaudible]
food and link to hill.
The three children, you know the dose
app and then you got the other ones.
Just like, you know, hey,
you know, I've got some bows.
You know, I got a dangling, I
want to stick it in your fucking
fucking Kooky all there. Whatever it is.
That's fucking amazing. God bless
this generation. You know what I mean?
That's fucking great. They have
that, you know, it's weird.
Every year like life becomes
easier. You have to think less,
but it gets more expensive. It's
fucking nuts. You know what I mean?
Okay.
I can tell you right now,
if there was fucking free porn and there
was these dating sites and how much
easier your fucking life would
have been when you were a kid,
just not having a fucking, Oh God, Jesus.
I remember having to go out
to those stupid fucking,
you just going out to these fucking clubs.
You know I was going out there and the
fucking late eighties walking into a
nightclub, bump up a doll, pop
it up and out. Bow, don't talk.
[inaudible] that girl
is boy then. Ah Yeah.
Inability would they have fucking
puppy as peds walking around.
We were in driving gloves inside.
Okay.
Fucking music. Loudest Shit in La.
Now you can sit there and your fucking
underwear just scrolling through people
like you're a fucking rock star on. You
know, like whenever you hear that shit,
like how the roadies would go out and
pick the fucking women that the band was
going to fuck and they'd be like, yeah,
you put your friends got his stay and
then the fucking friend would leave it.
She'd be like
Marcy.
And she just fucking walks
away just for one night.
Yeah.
With to, to fuck the guy. Some
guy from deep purple, right.
Or then years later, the
two of them mate, you know,
at a high school reunion and then the
fucker one that left the other one left
Marcy behind is all fucking nervous.
That Marcy's going to let her or
now husband know that she fucked,
you know the Maracas player,
the Maracas player from deep purple,
he wasn't even a full member. They just
had him on for that one fucking song.
Cause Santana's scared
the fuck out of him.
They thought that was the
direction of music was going to go.
Then once they realized that mainstream
music was only going to accept one
Santana, right.
And there wasn't going to be another
fucking type of Santana tell those guys
Bombo today. Yeah, boom layer. And then
there was Ricky Martin. How's that?
[inaudible] right. And years
fucking later they're at the,
they're at the fucking
heist, the ice core at union,
and she's just fucking with her
eyes. She's trying to be like, oh,
so to see you, she's fucking like
bringing her in. Like, you know,
trying to fucking sort of muffle her
and choke around like don't fucking say
shit to my husband. And then they fucking
around [inaudible] be powerful. Right.
And then Marcy, she's
just not, she's a woman.
She's just not going to come out and
say it was the fun there. Then the,
then it's over, you know, it's
like a cat playing with the mouse.
She's just got an linger. She's going
to start talking to the husband.
Yeah. Act It all interest. Not Looking
at fucking, you know Marcy. Right.
And then she's going to kind of glance
over at her and then she's just going to
just slowly let it out.
Yeah. Me and your wife. Yeah,
we were crazy back then.
Remember all those concert we went to
and she's just going to watch their,
I forget who's Marcy at this point.
The fucking chick who got lead.
We'll just say Marcy's the
married one. All right.
You just going to see her face
fucking fall. It says fucking chick.
Just twist the fucking knife. Is she
going to tell? Is she not going to tell?
And then she'll back off and change the
subject and then she'll gradually come
back around to it. And this
fucking guy's just standing there,
doesn't know a fucking
thing. Um, I'm sorry.
I was just, you know, I was just doing
a table read for a fucking screenplay.
I'm writing called a Marcy's a cunt.
You know,
and I've been shopping around Hollywood
forever and I'll tell you is great.
It's the script is for
whatever fucking reason,
they just cannot get
past the title, you know,
it's just this politically correct
age that we live in. All right,
let's get to some of the reeds here
for this week for Christ sake. Bill,
did you even fucking, did you even
fucking know you didn't? Yeah.
Here we go. All right, here we go.
Four reeds and don't Chino Indochino
the fuck is this.
Talk about how good it feels to have a
suit that is one of kindness is uniquely
yours. Talk about how when you
look good, you feel confident.
Let me talk about that.
Why don't you fucking write
some shit for me to talk about?
What is this? An interview? Talk about
wearing suits. All right. And No.
China window, Chino. Alright.
Indochino is reinventing. Oh,
I remember these guys.
Oh, these guys, actually,
I don't know why I'm shitting on
him. These guys are fucking great.
Hey do you didn't get, you know, I'll
talk about this. Hey, your man, your man.
When you had to go to that fucking thing
and you had to wear a fucking suit and
you put it on and you look like you
lost 30 pounds because it was your older
brothers,
you know when it'd be nice to have a
suit that just completely fit you was
totally custom made and measured.
A measured out your arms and
your legs and your crotch. Right.
And seeing how far down your balls hang.
We're not be great except it didn't
cost a zillion bucks or you couldn't do
that. But now there's Indochino Indochino.
They are reinventing men's fashion and
a made to measure suit is the best suit
you'll ever own. So suit up,
get a one of a kind made to measure suit,
custom customize as detailed as
you want. Pick your lining. Lapels,
personal monogram. There
you go. There's a good one.
Every chick,
even these feminists like when a guy
has his initials on the fucking cuffs,
right? And more the
fuck happened to the AC.
Okay,
14 unique measurements go into making
a suit that fits you perfectly.
You can't go wrong with the
well-crafted 100% Merino wool suit.
Also, check out who the fuck
buys a wool suit in August.
Also check out their made to measure
measured dress shirts and men's
accessories. Money back guarantee
ti money back guarantee.
Today my listeners get any premium
suit just for three 99 that's up to 50%
off@indochino.com when entering burr
at checkout plus shipping is free.
There's no reason not to try your
first custom made suit with the deal.
This good and [inaudible] in a classic
suit from their premium collection will
look good. Feel good and last.
That's indochino.com promo code bar.
Any premium suit for just
three 99 free shipping.
That's Indochino or China.
Look your look your way.
Okay, that was a rough one.
Alright. Oh, dollar shave club.
Dollar Shave Club dotcom delivers amazing
razors right to your door for a third
of the price. At what degree you
raise it. Corporations chats.
You know why they don't give a fuck, dude,
that means you can join dollar shave club.
You can afford to shave with a
fresh blade anytime you want,
which feels fantastic.
You get a first class shave when you
use the executive blade. Oh yeah.
And that's without even
hurting your wallet.
And when you use the executive
razor with Dr Cabbies,
easy shave.
The play just glides gently
for the smoothest shave ever.
Shave butter do. People can
do cocaine off your cheek.
That's how fucking smooth it's going
to beach dice it right up. Oh God.
That would hurt. Shave butter
isn't your average shave cream.
It's a unique conditioning formula
with high quality natural ingredients,
leaving your skin
unbelievably soft and smooth.
Now's a great time to join dollar
shave club. New members who buy a tub,
a tube, sorry, of shave butter. Get a
month of the executive razor for free.
Take advantage of this
special offer today.
It's available by going to dollar
shave club.com/bird that's dollar shave
club.com/berm all right, what do we got
left? Two more. Two more. Hang in there.
Score big.
You're paying too much for tickets
between all the markups and last minute
convenience charges. Even printed
home phase. You're fucking kidding me.
Do you end up paying court side
prices for nosebleed seats?
ScoreBig is here to change all of that.
Did you know that 40% of all live event
tickets go on soul and did you know
there's a place to get
these take and a huge site?
It's called ScoreBig score.
Bid Works directly with your favorite
teams and artists to get their unsold
seats at unpublished prices.
All Li with score big.
Can you name a ticket price?
I want it for free and be guaranteed
to pay below box office up to 60% off.
Here's what you got to do.
You don't have to do it,
but this is what you should do. One Uno,
go to scorebig.com or download the news.
I just realized when French people,
fuck do they, does a woman thinks she
the guy's counting or does he just,
you know, fucking you know, ah, uh, sorry.
Ah,
go to score big.com or download the new
score big app for your iPhone and find
the event and seats you want.
Make an offer with score.
Biggs name a ticket,
uh, price feature show.
Get an instant answer then save
up to 60% off your tickets.
Never ready. Fees in
shipping is always free.
You can count on and unbeatable
prices and great seats.
And when you're in great seats you
actually enjoy the game or the show.
All the more. Yeah,
because you've got more chance of being
next to some gold digging or I might
give you a fucking handy if you've got
your initials on your sleeve there.
Next time you go see any game a show,
go to score big first and see how much
she can save for the easiest Jesus
Christ. We get it for the
easiest way to save on tickets.
Download the new score,
big app for your iPhone.
Enter the Promo Code Byrd at checkout and
you'll save an extra 20 bucks off your
first tickets per purchase.
No iPhone, no problem.
Go steal one bunch of
old lady and they had,
they'll get the $20 off online to
get $20 off online too. What score?
big.com that score big.com Promo Code
Bar, scorebig.com promo code birth.
Lastly, but not leastly,
stamps.com everybody you know,
trips to the post office have
probably become second nature to you.
They seem easy because you've been doing
your mailing and shipping that way for
so long,
and you live in a first world country so
you don't have to walk nine miles with
a basket on your head to go get some
water while you fight off a cobra.
But think about all the hassle, man.
Dropping what you're doing to driving
there, finding parking and waiting.
There's a much better way
it stamps.com everybody stamps.com as
easy as convenient way to get postage
right from your desk.
Buy and print official US postage using
your own computer and printer with
stamps.com there is no guesswork. You
don't have to thank you fucking dope.
They make it easy to get exact postage
for any letter. Package, classic mail,
the instinct, you need it. No
expensive postage meters to lease.
No more trips to the post office. You
have to try it. You don't have to,
but you should. I use stamps.com
anytime I'm paying, you know,
I've got to ship out my posters,
then I'm going to whore myself out.
Made the public. Every 11th person's
going to have a fucking sweaty palm.
Maybe there'll be a tall guy can put his
arm around me and I can feel the heat
of his sweaty armpit. Making my right
shoulder blade damp through my shirt.
Sign up for stamps.com and use my last
name, bird for this special offer.
Four week trial plus $110 bonus offer
that includes the postage and a digital
scale. Don't wait. Go to stamps.com
before you do anything else,
click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburrthatstamps.com
enter
[inaudible].
All right, now that we
got that out of the way,
it's time to go back for the bullets. Uh,
did anybody watch the hunk
Hungary Grand Prix yesterday?
Cool.
Did you, well, did you, um,
Lewis Hamilton wins again?
Nico Rosberg came in second and
now Lewis Hamilton. That's the,
that's the fifth time he won
that race and I learned that, uh,
he passed our Craig shoemaker
stand up comedian and legendary.
A fucking f one driver.
No, Michael Schumacher.
Um, every four, every other Grand
Prix drivers. Sounds like the,
the guitarist and Scorpions and
the Scorpions, I should say. Um,
you always fucked up about that. Tran.
I don't know shit about this sport.
It's just seem whoever was in first like,
like the race was to the first turn
and then it was just fucking over you.
You couldn't get past anybody, you know,
who is that fucking lunatic zigzag
and behind the red bull. Huh?
Going back and forth, he cut off
the front of his fucking car.
Was it Sebastian Vettel
was at Max per stopping.
Ladies and gentlemen.
Um, Kimmy Raikkonen was the
driver of the day. I've,
he was in like in fucking 90th place
and he moved up to like seventh to some
shit. Uh, [inaudible] heads. It's warm.
It's race for fourth was really
entertaining, but I didn't like how that,
you know, there was no way for fucking
Nico to even try to pass Lewis.
Once he got out in front, that
fucking track, it was just, you know,
kind of stunk. Like Lewis Hamilton
was just driving around and
right. The whole fucking
time. And you know,
they would just show in like the race for
fourth and fifth and third and fourth.
And then like they were on the final lap
and it was so fucking boring out front.
They was still back, you know, watching
that Guy Zigzag. Hey Formula One fans,
I don't understand where they, I
like the fucking rules. Well Bill,
why don't you look them up? Well,
it's easier to ask you guys.
It's also funny or if I talk about them
and I don't know what I'm talking about,
I don't get out when the guy who
cut off the front of his car, right.
One of the fucking fins. I did find
it funny that they were like, yeah,
people do that all the time and it
doesn't affect the performance of the car.
Um, doesn't seem to anyways, um,
where they was saying you were
only allowed to make one move,
like you went to the right and then he
came back to the left and then back to
the right. And that was considered more
than one move. And I was just like,
what the fuck? You can't do that.
I thought I left this behind with the
NFL season you this is like, you know,
he's got to make a football move.
That fucking guy, when
he tried to go around,
the other dude didn't do anything that
I don't do when I'm on the highway,
when I'm behind some fucking Douche
driving too fucking slow in the left lane,
right?
Yeah.
Oh, you know what [inaudible] and I'm
in the, I'm in the second to left lane.
Right.
And there's some guy driving medium
speed and then somebody doing that just
making a wall. And I'm like, what the
fuck? What the fuck? What the fuck?
What the fuck? And then
you go around to the right.
Okay.
Coming around now when I watched
the race, it was Lewis Hamilton,
then Rosberg and I
remember it was a red bull,
then a Ferrari, then a
red bull, then a Ferrari.
And then today it's saying red
bull, Ferrari, Ferrari, red bull.
So did somebody get penalized?
It's fucking unreal.
I don't get it. Like, it's, there's
always like, after the fucking, Oh,
you thought you won the race, but,
uh, somebody said something in ta,
don't shift into seventh gear. And
they're like, oh, you can't do that.
Don't tell him what he
shouldn't do. You know,
he's only driving a car at
200 fucking miles an hour.
One guy spun up, that was it.
There wasn't really any crashes or
anything like that, but it was funny.
I'm actually totally into
it. My wife can't stand it.
She says when I have it on, it sounds
like a bunch of bees flying around,
but um, it's still fucking coolest
shit. Although that, I dunno,
that was probably of all the races I've
watched, that's been my least favorite.
Um, just because there was
all this, like the, the,
the start of the race was the most
exciting and then it was just a bunch of
people in the back trying to go around
people and they couldn't do it except for
Kimmy. Raikkonen the flying Finn
evidently see the flying Finn.
I have no fucking idea. Um, anyways,
but this is really getting me through
the fucking dog days of baseball.
I fucking love baseball,
but I just, you know,
I can't get into it in July and
August. I like it in April, you know,
into May.
You start seeing what's going to happen
and then I just fucking veg out. June,
July, August, the same
way the players do, right?
They're just standing up there
like, dude, what the fuck?
How many fucking games do you have to
play in the regular season before we know
who deserves to win the
division hundred and 62 five.
Isn't that, isn't that insane?
[inaudible]
that has to be, if you're going
to own a professional team,
that's gotta be the sport
to do it. 162 home games.
If your teams selling out
the Ballpark, Jesus Christ,
those things have to be, I've got to
look this up right now. Look at this.
I'm actually going to do
research professional.
See, I know franchises.
Okay.
I should have put sports
in there right now.
If suddenly going to be fucking
talking to being about McDonald's
worth the most.
Okay.
Okay. Well, this is everything. Okay.
The Dallas cowboys, for whatever reason,
are worth $4 billion. Real Madrid,
I'm guessing is some sort of
football club in Spain is where?
Three point $7 billion
and then there's another one in
Barcelona. Is that also Spain?
3.6 billion. The New York
Yankees. There you go.
Well that makes sense that like
a world football as we call it,
soccer would be worth that
much money cause that's,
that really is when you're
winning a world championship,
you're winning the World Cup. You're
playing against the fucking world, right?
It's like an Olympic medal, except you
get paid a, then the New York Yankees,
3.4 billion, then man United 3.3 billion.
Oh, and then the New England patriots.
Everybody's favorite fucking
team to hate on 3.2 billion.
Then the New York Knicks. What?
3 billion.
Okay.
Jesus Christ. No New York. I'll tell
you, that's a fixer upper right.
That New York, nextera.
A fucking tear down. Oh,
this is weird man. Then the
Washington Redskins, 2.9 billion
invaluable sports team
in the world. The NFL.
[inaudible] this year's list by force.
Shut up.
We're feeling good dollars.
I hate when this happens. Yeah.
Now you've got to figure out where
the fuck the voice is coming from.
Rankings in 2011 that he soccer.
Shut up. Oh, there it is.
All right.
All right. The Redskins
are worth 2.9 billion.
Then the giants are 2.8
building, building billion.
Then the Lakers a 2.7 the Lakers
are worth less than the Knicks.
If anything says that this state is
going to fall into the ocean one day,
it's the fact that the fucking nicks
are with more fucking money than the
fucking Lakers. Jesus Christ.
What are the Celtics worth?
Oh my God. Rappaport's
gonna fucking love that.
Well,
you know something that actually makes
sense because you know when you move to
Manhattan, you fuck. Can you
fucking let me get to the site?
I hate when fucking sites do this.
They just got to suck the fucking
information out of you, Forbes,
to give you my fucking email.
What so time magazine can start
fucking spam and me. I don't think so.
Why Hillary Clinton should be
thankful. Election is not today.
I don't know why is there pantsuits all
in the fucking dry cleaners. All right,
let's uh, let's, let's do sway of
where am I? How much time have I done?
41 minutes. You know,
some days it feels like work
other days that doesn't, um,
you know, I've become obsessed with
as of last night is, is uh, you know,
I've been doing this grip strength thing
and I've been fucking doing great man.
I can go up a pegboard
now at 48 years of age.
I can go up a climbing rope leaving my
skinny fucking Alabaster fucking albino
legs just dangling like
a fucking, I don't know,
couple of appendixes, right? Jesus.
I never had to make that plural.
Appendix. Appendix is, um, tits. Today's
um,
yeah, cause you know what? I got
those, those atomic fucking holds.
Those motherfuckers better
send me some free shit.
I'm sick of hyping those guys up, but
they, they shit, they are the shit.
So now I want to be
able to do one of those,
is it called a front lever
or a front lever? Um,
and I watched this guys a youtube
video. I'll, I'll repost it.
The six easy steps, eh, hey,
lovely mia to being able
to do a front lever.
Um,
did you hear about Paula
Abdul? No. What? She's,
she's a singer and she was a Laker girl.
[inaudible]
Paul Abdul at the national job. No,
I have to eat my cereal. Oh, okay.
I just brought you some of this. Thank
you. Come over onto the Mike. Mike.
Mike Baby Dude. Why did you do
that? About Paula Abdul. Um,
cause I love Paula Abdul.
I know I liked Megan.
I had to pick someone, you
know, if I was like, yeah, go.
Did you hear about Paula Abdul? Like
that's not funny. What is funny?
It is funny.
And you're going to sit there and act
like you're not going to do it to me.
That's true. Who would you pick? Hmm?
One of your rock icons probably, you know,
kind of helps you pick a name. Well,
I can't tell you because then it's not
going to be a surprise when I do it right
? No, it isn't because you already
told me you're going to do it.
See what I did there? Uh Oh yeah, I guess,
but I can flip it. I don't know.
It's, it's the morning still here.
Drink some of your juice. I
brought it for you. Oh thank you.
Well I got to do a podcast if you don't
mind just journey right now though. No,
I people give me shit cause I
try not to drink on the mic,
but I have to hold the microphone.
Just take a sip. All right.
Then talk to them while I drink it.
Okay. So on my snapchat last night,
if you guys follow me on Snapchat,
I made my fresh squeeze watermelon
juice and I'm giving it to bill.
Who loves a wow. He's
taking it down like a champ.
You give me anything in this glass? I
suck it down. Just like my, my juice.
I drink at night. Daddy's Madison,
Daddy's medicine. Um, all right,
I gotta get back to the podcast,
Nia. Okay. Alrighty. All right. Okay.
What you're talking about,
um, I don't really know.
This has just been one of these
stream of conscious stays. Um,
that's their whole podcast.
I've talked about some lady with a basket
on her head trying to get water once
she fought off a cobra.
I do remember that.
And I also talked about how big the
heads are of the people running for
president and how I'd be concerned
if I was the head of security. Okay.
What else? That's all I
can remember. Oh, riveting.
Okay. All right, I'll see you.
Hey neenee do you hear about Lady Gaga?
She had a meat dress. Alright,
let's get to some of the
questions here. Um, oh yeah.
So I became obsessed with the, uh,
that front lever and uh,
this guy has a six step thing on how to
do it cause I always wanted to be able
to do the human fucking flag. You know,
that's just a great thing to be
able to do if you're not a gymnast.
Cause people just expect you to be able
to do it. But if you just like a dad,
you've got a couple of kids, you know,
you fucking into roofing now that's a
physical job. Whatever you fucking build.
I don't know.
It just be something just funny to do
that day that you could actually fucking
do that. Just weird people out.
Um, you know what that reminds me,
I wanted to do a bit on these
fucking crossfit people,
but I just feel like it's just too hacky
and every comics going to have a bid on
it. So what, what's, why
do these crossfit people,
why do they have to like work out
in the gym and outside? Why is,
it's just so fucking, look at me.
We're working out. I work out too.
I work out my garage with
the fucking door closed.
It's the most narcissistic shit you ever
see when they just like did fucking run
down the street with like a goddamn
fucking tire behind them. Right.
Somebody show me a picture of a guy
doing that. Every tweeted it right.
Running down the street, dragging a
tire. When you just run up a hill,
you fucking moron, you know?
Oh cause the tire adds more difficulty
when they've run up the hill more times.
Increase your reps, you stupid. Fuck
well what do you train
in for the standards?
I was fucking somewhere in Santa
Monica. These fucking jerk offs.
It's like 10 of them
outside and they've got,
you know when they got
the double fucking ropes,
that thing that they do that,
the only reason you really need to do
that is if you're fighting in the UFC.
They're the only people who
seem to need to have to do that.
Then everybody else wants to be in UFC
shape without having to actually have the
balls to get in the octagon. All right,
so fucking dumb. And the,
or even when they're inside,
there's like down the
street, there's one from me,
it's like this giant garage and they
just have it open. Like, look at us.
We're crossfitting. I talked to Nia
about and she was saying like, yeah,
it was like all the rage to be on one
of those social media things and like,
oh I did, you know, take filming yourself,
working out Hashtag
crossfit. It's just, I dunno
when I was a s when I was a kid, if
you wanted people to look at you,
you got into show business. Okay? You
became a male stripper. You told jokes,
you joined a band.
You know now these fucking assholes that
they're making a bunk cake and they got
like fucking 80,000 fucking hits and
everybody's walking around with the same
arrogance that I have. It's,
it's not fair people I earned,
I earned my Eric, it's
um, I'm fucking with you.
You want to work outside.
You want to run down the street
with a fucking tire behind you.
Okay.
You know what I mean?
I don't quite understand when to apply
the white privilege thing because I am
white and who's kidding who I am
one of the widest of all time.
You know what I mean?
I would say Hitler would not be
disappointed if I walked into his office,
but I think the red hair,
I think I might be out.
Okay.
[inaudible] chuck white skin,
chuck on the Blue Eyes. All
this one's defective. Alright.
If you want to help donate to this podcast
without having to do fucking anything
except buy something on
amazon.com just go to my website,
Bill byrd.com okay, and
there's an Amazon app there.
You Click on that thing. It
takes you right to Amazon.
It doesn't cost you any extra money.
I just get credit for driving traffic
to their site and then they kicked me a
little doe ray me, you
didn't have to do nothing.
Nobody knows anything
and you know, whatever.
I go out and I buy myself a
ham sandwich. You can do it.
If you want to get dope, that's fine.
If you're listening to this podcast and
you're like, I hate this thing, Gee,
I wish there was a podcast network.
They had had a bunch of other
podcasts to choose from.
I would say to go to all things,
comedy.com the podcast network started
by myself and Al Madrigal and a bunch of
other people. We've got
Irish, a fear over there.
I should really go onto
the website right now.
We'll give you and give you a
bunch of fucking names, right?
Oh,
okay.
Things. Comedy, right?
Of all the people I used
to podcast with. Um,
all right. What do we have
here? Oh, we got Dean del Rey's.
Let Debbie Talk.
Um,
Chris Sane and Anna David. I
have no control over my vagina.
How do you not fucking listen
to that? We got Steve Simone.
Uh,
we got Doug's Stan hope.
No, I'm my fucking God.
Damn. Eyes had going. I can't even
read half of these fucking things.
Are we shift gears. Skeptic tank. We got a
with Erin Foley sports
without balls. I mean we, we,
we get whatever the fuck you want. We got
it over there. All things. comedy.com.
All right, let's read some shit
here for this week, shall we?
50 minutes in Professor
Dick Wad. Hey Bill,
you hemoglobin laden Aretha site.
I had to look all of that up.
That's basically a scene. I have a lot
of red in me. A lot of red blood cells.
I guess let's make this as short and
sweet as possible. Hey, all right.
Why are you fucking don't lecture me
you cunt. Um, I go to a nice college.
I also manage a movie
theater in my town too.
Why would you say also and too, I
manage a movie theater in my town also,
or two to one also mean
the same thing. Right.
I also manage it movie theater
in my town to comma to alright,
at school, I've got a film,
even said you're gonna make it short
and sweet at school. I've got a,
I got a film studies class with one of
those pretentious fucking professors that
wears young kid clothes to come
off cooler than he really is. Yeah.
You know what that means? He's gonna
fuck us, don't it? I love movies.
I've seen plenty of them. That's the
reason why I'm taking this class. Well,
that's great. Gravitate
towards you what you want.
Every time before we watch
a movie in this class,
the professor asks us to raise
our hands if we've seen it before.
I raised my hand almost every time that
I look around to see if anyone else is
raising their hand. They
rarely are. Sure I'm a nerd.
I've seen the fucking movies. Maybe if
he didn't play the most standard choices,
like Cassa blanket and shit, I wouldn't
raise my hand every time. Look at that.
You like movies, you're doing your
homework, you taking a class on it,
you're gravitating towards what
you want. Very nice. All right.
So anyway, I was just recently hired.
I was just recently hired on an employee.
Dude, you're killing me. I just
recently hired on as an employee.
You left out the ass at my theater. Um,
who also happens to be a
student of my film studies Pref.
Oh, you went by an employee.
So anyway, I just recently,
I was just recently hired by an employee
at my theater who also happens to be a
student of my film studies professor,
but in a different class
at a different school.
I think I conveyed what you were
trying to say that as a joke.
One day I asked the kid,
so does Mr So-and-so ever
talk shit about our class?
The kid looks me square in the eye
and says, yeah, actually he does.
Doctor So-and-so says
there's this one kid in your,
your your all's class,
you mean y'alls class?
Who always raises his hand when
he asks if he's seen the movie.
But really he probably hasn't.
And then he looks around the run and
makes sure everyone is looking at him to
know he's seen the movie
before. That's hilarious.
This guy's getting insecure. You're
making your teacher insecure.
So now he's got a Jesus.
That's probably why he's wearing
the young people's clothes.
He's talking shit about the other
class to make himself seem cool. Ah,
this guy's a fucking, this guy's a bitch.
I don't like this teacher. He goes,
so there we go.
This guy talks shit about me to his other
classes when all I'm doing is gently
raising my hand after being asked
if I've seen the movie or not.
In any other case, I'd probably
just confront him about this,
but I don't want to risk failing the
class. There's something petty like that.
Am I overthinking this? What should I
do here? I'd walked right up to the guy.
I just want, who gives a fuck
this fucking insecure comment?
He'll probably give you a better
grade cause what does need to be like?
Just walk right up to him.
But yeah. Listen man, uh,
there seems to be some confusion on your
part that you seem to be trying to work
out with the other class as to why I
raised my hand every time I happen to love
movies, I work at a movie theater. Okay.
And I've seen all these movies and I look
around just to see if anybody else has
seen the movies.
Cause I love movies and I want to talk
to people about movies if he don't want
me to keep, you know, raising my hand.
Stop doing this paint by numbers. Basic
Horse Shit movies that you keep picking.
What are you going to have
next week? Days of Duh. Huh?
Okay.
You've given me shit. You're
going to come in here.
Dress like you could go
into a fucking, yeah.
One of the young kids listened to,
I used to just go see the weekend.
Is that the right thing?
Who's the other guy?
Who's the rapper who won all the
fucking grammys? Kendrick Lamar.
I know who they are. I don't,
I know a few of their songs.
Okay.
I know the weekends CD
starts off going right.
Wait
[inaudible]
you can actually play the
beginning of the weekend.
I think rednecks do it as much as they
probably don't like your skin color.
They probably play that when
they're out. Duck hunting
to try to get the young ducks. You
know, we're into all this fucking, um,
I'm fucking with you.
I'm a fan of the weekend.
I wasn't rattled a little
[inaudible] that anyway,
it was hard to write that last
y'all guy little Apollo. All right,
I'm a Billy calorie count.
Thoughts on Melissa Muck.
Kathy getting flack for losing weight.
Uh, all right, my first thought,
I'm Melissa McCarthy.
I did a movie with her a number of years
ago was called the heat directed by
Paul Feig starring Melissa
McCarthy, Sandra Bullock.
And that's where I first met,
uh, Michael Rappaport, you know,
um, dropping names all over the place and
she is truly one of the most naturally
funny fucking hilarious human beings
I have ever met and she's an absolute
sweetheart. Um, so anyways, I didn't
realize people would give him,
why would you give somebody
flagged for losing weight?
Aren't you supposed to say,
hey, great job, good for you.
Okay.
You know. Anyway.
Say people are saying she's doing
it because of Hollywood pressures.
That's so fucking dumb. All right.
Yeah. People are just add, isn't it?
That's not what it is. It's, it's,
it's, it's the same towny mentality.
When you're, you're finally
deciding that, you know,
wearing your football jacket and
continuing to drink in the local bar,
you want more out of life and then all
a gong call forgetting a part also.
What do you think is smart
now? Like all of them,
they don't want to see her get
her shit together. You know,
misery loves fucking company. You know,
they would stay here and be out of
shape. Good for her. Fucking assholes.
What kind of an asshole? When somebody
makes a positive move in their life,
tries to make it negative. Well me,
I'm a comedian. I do that all the time.
But besides people like me anyways,
these people who always say you should
be comfortable in your own body,
no matter what you look like,
completely ignore basic information like
clogged arteries and such. Absolutely.
Maybe Melissa Carte McCarthy doesn't
want to die of a heart attack because she
wants to meet her grandchildren's one
day I lost 30 pounds since listening to
you fat. Shame everyone. I honestly
didn't know I was getting fat.
I was never fat ever. But then three
years in an office job in college,
I'm 24 I put on the gross 30.
I recently lost. Yeah Dude.
At 24, man, you are headed towards being,
you are going to die if you are 30 pounds
overweight at 24 that is not a good
thing. So congratulations. Anyways,
he said I feel a thousand times better.
I never looked fat because I'm
a tall guy and I carry it well.
So I never heard anything from
anyone. I did it on my own for myself.
These fat defenders are ignorantly judging
and assuming thoughts on this. Also,
when the fuck do we get
to see your gym video,
I want to see your pasty legs dangling
from a pull up bar like meat hanging in a
locker. Ah, you fucking cuts. Uh, no.
This is the thing about this business. Uh,
the only pressure that it
is as far as I'm concerned,
the only pressure in this
business is what you x.
You as an individual choose to accept.
All right?
And everybody does it to a certain point
when you first get into entertainment
because you don't know
what the fuck you're doing.
You come into this business with
your hat in hand, you're like,
I'll sweep the floors, I'll do whatever
you want. Just give me stage time. I'll,
I'll drive to another state to do five
minutes for no money for $5 gas money.
We all do that shit. Um,
but at some point you then have to put
a value on what the fuck it is you're
doing, right? And then
you start getting paid.
Then what happens is you're like
going, fuck. You know, you know,
you get in this business,
it takes a while to get going and
everybody starts creeping into 30.
So you start freaking out going, oh,
what is, what is the industry casting?
What are they looking at?
What is the blah, blah,
Blah and all that type of shit. Okay. Now,
a lot of people do not ever get past that
because they don't put a value on that
talent. And I'm not even
talking monetarily. This is
just my own belief system.
You have to believe that you have
something to say that you know,
you know, you can't be married to the
results. You just gotta do that Zen thing.
Like I'm talking about this shit,
I'm doing this and like take me all right?
I came in and the business, all
right, a fucking redheaded con male,
you know? So from day one, there's
not going to be a lot of rules for me.
There's not a lot of redheaded male
leads and shit. You know, I'm the friend,
right? That's the deal.
That's how it works.
The Red Ed and male is not the fucking
cool guy. So to make matters worse,
I started losing my fucking
hair and I was like, ah, fuck.
Now what do I go out and get plugs
and all that shit and just one day,
right? You know, Neil was just,
just bus your fucking head down.
And I was just like, and I just came to
this epiphany of just like, yeah, Bill,
why are you walking around like you
losing your fucking hair is a big deal.
Does that mean you're not funny
anymore? Does that mean you know,
what were you going to be the next
Brad Pitt if you kept your fucking hair
right? And then I just
said, yeah, fuck it.
So then I did it and this and I ever
since I had the philosophy of basically
this is what I look like
and this is what I do.
If you want to book me, thank
you. If you don't, I understand.
The second I went into that mindset,
I never fucking stressed again.
So I really think that
all that whole, you know,
the pressures of fucking Hollywood is,
I understand that when you're young,
but as you're getting
older you have to fucking,
it really has nothing to
do with Hollywood. I also,
I think it has more to do with, you
know, why you got into this business,
you know, the self-loathing, you
know, and not liking yourself.
I think, and I have to tell you a,
this past weekend I watched
Allie Wong special and um,
it was so fucking great.
And I was sitting there with my wife
and I was saying like what I loved.
She went out there and it just
was, she was fucking original.
All of us stuff was just, it was just
fucking, it was just a great set.
It was worthy like this, it
really was a standup special.
And you know, she's, she
went out there, you know,
and everybody's making a
big fucking deal that like,
because she was pregnant that
she did it. Oh my goodness.
All these fucking questions. And
I understand why they did that.
Cause no one's ever done that.
But there should be more questions
about how great the material was.
But I was saying to my wife when I
was watching this, I go, you see this?
She had a special to do and she didn't
give a fuck that she was pregnant and she
just walked out and then she owned it.
And now what she's done is she's
established herself that now she can just
basically do whatever the fuck she
wants. She wants to have another kid.
She can literally go on
tour while pregnant because
she's established that this
is who I am. This is what
I'm doing. I'm married,
I'm starting to fucking family
and I'm writing killer jokes.
This is what I'm doing now.
All these fucking feminist who sit
there going alien again. Hollywood love,
let you be pregnant.
I would argue your giving them
way too much fucking power.
Way Too much power. Just go out.
If every fucking woman out here just
started getting pregnant cause they wanted
to and continue to go on auditions, the
whole fucking business would adjust.
You, make it adjust to you rather than
the other fucking way around. And um,
if you haven't seen her
special, you know, you know,
a lot of the hype on it is the fact
that she did at seven months pregnant.
But I'm telling you, just as,
uh, someone who still f you know,
as long as I've been doing this, a huge
fan of standup comedy, you know, um,
it's the jokes of a fucking killer.
The subject matter, all of it.
It was just like, you know, God knows
it's a Zillion fucking specials out there,
but you know, every once in awhile,
you know, someone comes out like with,
with that, that was, that was one of the
best ones I've seen in awhile. So, um,
I guess I would tie all of
that back into that. It's like,
I would say that she's losing
weight. Yeah. She's married,
she's got kids and who the fuck
doesn't want to lose weight?
I'm trying to lose weight. No one
wants to walk around being overweight.
It's not fun. Your life is
easier. And people who, uh,
give a shit about that, I
would just say, you know,
I feel bad for them because I know
they don't want to be out of shape too.
You know? I mean [inaudible] like
being proud to be out of shape.
That's like being proud to be like
a fucking alcoholic, you know,
you know you've got issues. You,
your fucking heart isn't fucking
excited that you're overweight. Like,
that's right.
Every pound of fat is five
miles of capillaries. You know,
you get 20 pounds overweight,
your heart's got to fucking go an
extra hundred miles every fucking beat.
You stupid. It's not, it's
not a good thing to be doing.
So congratulations to
her. Um, and you know,
I'm struggling right now to lose
fucking weight. Oh, I'll tell you,
it's not easy. Well, Billy
booze bag. All right.
A Christian girls sexual
boundaries. Hey Billy Bo Berman.
I listen to all your specials multiple
times and really loved the advice
segments you do on your podcast.
I'm back home for the summer from my
first year of college and I'm hooking up
with this six to 10. Chris, what?
Oh six out of 10 Christian girl the
last couple of months of school.
I barely even just retained any of that
cause I was hoping everything that I
said came off as positive. And
that last thing, um, anyway,
let me reread this.
I've listened to all your saying that
the dad back for the summer. Okay.
I'm hooking up with this girl,
this six out of 10 Christian girl,
the last couple months of school.
The encounter is basically consisted
of me aggressively finger bla Jeez.
Easy finger blasting her to
quench her sexual deviancy.
Oh, I love how you're just fucking
innocent in all this and her giving my,
Oh, okay. Okay. Oh,
this is a woman rightness and hurricanes
are given my carpet. A midnight snack.
What? Oh No, this is a guy.
Why are you saying your carpet?
Giving my carpet a midnight snack while
jerking me off. You lost me in that one.
What is your carpet? Your pubes.
What does the snack cause
you come on yourself.
I don't even know what's
going on here. Anyway,
she's a devout Christian so she won't
get involved with oral sex or anything
further a, the thing is her
idea of boundaries are pretty,
uh, a morphous. I don't know what
that means. Nah, you fucking asshole.
Now I gotta look, you know
what, actually keep doing this.
Maybe I'll get smart one day. A morphous
amorphous without a clear,
defined shape or form.
How did I never hear that?
My whole fucking life?
There's so many fucking words in English
language and then they always say that,
but we use like 19 of them. Four
of them are curse words. All right?
She's begged me to pleasure her
with the hilt of my screwdriver.
Dude, are you from another century? What
the fuck is a hilt? Is that the handle?
Don't know why I even had one at college
and jerk me off onto her face when we
took a late night sleepover
shower together. Ah,
yeah, but that's not really a
facial when the water's right there.
You know what I mate, that's like,
you know, you're going to run,
you're going to go walk on some hot rocks
and you just fucking do a running leap
and touch one for half a second. You
keep going, right? She's also into being,
it's like picking up dog shit with the
little fucking plastic bag around your
hand. You know, you're still touching
dog shit, but you feel the warmth of it.
But you know, there's
a boundary there. Uh,
she's also into being
choked and tied up to her.
Jesus fucking Christ
up during dry humping.
Apparently that stuff's still
Christian enough for her.
I've had sex a few
times before this. Cute.
Why are you judging this
girl so harshly? All right.
This is this religion thing. This is
where she's at. Just fucking relaxed.
It seems like you having a hell of a
time because I had sex a few times before
this girl and know that even protected
fucking is infinitely more pleasurable
than outsource masturbation.
My question to you is,
do you think she'll ever
realize how ridiculous it is
to take a load on her face
but not accept kind of Linkous
will she ever want premarital sex?
I know I should go to
a gym, lose this girl,
get some sleep and take
advantage of the pussy Colosseum.
That is my universe
camp, university campus,
but I'm lazy and want to
fuck the low hanging fruit.
What can I do to convince her that
college, sexist, natural, wholesome.
It would make her feel incredible.
Thanks so much and go fuck yourself.
I would say, you should
let this girl go because a,
you don't have any feelings
for you using as a,
you're using her as a fucking blow
up doll. You just say, you know,
I know I should go meet some other people,
but this girl's an easy
fucking sex hookup. Um,
I dunno, I mean, meantime, is
she getting feelings for you?
Because if you just sitting there hanging
around waiting to be able to fuck her,
so then you can then leave, um, you're
already saying she's a six out of 10.
That's, that doesn't sound like you have
feelings for her. So I'd let her go.
I'd let her go and I'd find some girl
then just, and just let them know,
you're young, so I'm not judging you
here. What you got to do early on,
and this is what nobody
ever tells young men,
it's just just out of the gate.
Tell women what the deal is. All
right. Because believe it or not,
they can have fun. We eat. They don't
flip out when you just say, yeah,
there's no way I'm going
to marry you. You know,
if you say it right from the beginning,
the second you meet them, right?
If you're not feeling anything
but you're just attracted to them,
just tell them that and just
fucking let them, you know,
work that out.
And maybe they're in the same place
you are and they just want to fuck.
They don't want to have a relationship.
But if you get into that
type of a situation, you've
got to make sure that you,
you got to have like, you know,
you fuck and then you don't call each
other or talk or do anything else.
You do not hang out and there's gotta
be at least 10 days between the fucking
hookups or, or somebody starts failing
something and then it's a fucking mess.
Or they get jealous cause you
with somebody else. So whatever.
You know what I mean? And this is what
you fucking say from day one. You,
you tell him that. All right, let's deal,
we're going to hook up anything
you ever wanted to fucking do.
You can do with me. You're
not going to get judged.
You have to worry about getting judged
because it is what it is. Right?
And then that's it. We
don't call each other.
This is what we just fucking
use each other for this.
Anytime you're feeling already, if
you're not in a fucking relationship,
I don't give a shit if you date
other people, believe it or not.
If you come out of the
gate with that Shit,
you would be surprised how many
women are also looking for that.
It's a great fuck fuck buddy is.
It's the greatest thing ever.
Greatest fucking thing ever. It's
like having fucking, I don't know,
free tickets to Disneyland. You
get to ride all the fucking rides.
You know you've got VIP parking. It's
like ordering a pizza. It's tremendous.
And you know what? Women also order
a pizza, if you know what I mean.
So have fun with that. But let
this girl go, man. All right.
First Time flying at 30 years of age. Hey,
they have Billy the ginger bats.
Just want to say I've been a huge fan
for over 10 years and have loved every
special you had. Well,
thank you very much.
I'm 30 I've never been on a plane and
heights kind of freaked me out to top it
off. My flight is on nine 11 and
makes two stops in between here,
Connecticut in Chicago.
I'm going there for my job and I'd really
hate to miss out on the opportunity.
Basically,
I'm just looking for advice and how to
not freak out and look like a fucking
idiot on the plane. Seeing as how
you've had so much experience flying,
I'd figured you'd be a good person to
talk to. Thanks and go fuck yourself. Um,
yeah. It's no big deal. It's
completely safe and uh, you know,
you're going to be fine. This is the
deal. You're going to go up there, right?
This is what you do.
Get on the plane and then just
say to the person next to you yet,
believe it or not, this is the
first time I've ever flown,
hopefully not next to a douche. If
they'd seem open, just tell them that.
All right. But to believe
me, you're not going to,
if you ever just stomped on the gas when
you've been driving a car and you just
get back in your seat,
it's just sorta like that and then
you fucking up in the air and it's the
coolest thing ever. It's fucking great.
And you're going to go from fucking
Connecticut to Chicago in like fucking two
seconds. You know, we got two stops
there. Okay, well that's cool. Be Fun,
you know, then you'll be a veteran by
the end of it and yeah, welcome to the,
uh, the, the fucking 21st century.
You're going to be fine. Um,
what I would say is, you know, just, uh,
make sure you eat well before
you go to the airport, you know,
maybe bring some food to go
onto the plane, you know,
because the food and the plane sucks.
It's fucking overpriced and that
type of thing. And uh, you know,
that's the only thing I
would say. Other than that,
you have nothing to worry
about. It's going to be great.
Get a fucking window seat too, if
you can. That's the best, you know,
first time you fly, you
get to look down. Um,
it's actually pretty incredible to be
doing that at 30 years of age cause you
can actually take it in. You know,
I came the first time I flew,
I was so young that I don't
ever have that. Like, oh,
this is what it looks like from the
fucking year. Um, you'll be fine. All
Right William, I've been dating
my girls. This is the last one.
And then I gotta I gotta get off my
day here of doing absolutely nothing.
William William,
I've been dating my girl for a few years
now and everything started out great.
However, over the course
of the past few months,
I've noticed a sudden change in her
behavior and was wondering if he's dealt
with anything like this before. Yeah.
She's either using drugs or fucking
someone else. Um, or she's depressed.
I'm fucking with you. Let
me read the rest of this.
Basically when we hang out lately,
she just won't stop asking questions.
She may ask, what are you listening
to? I might say the bill bird podcast.
Then she will ask, why I don't
know, because I enjoy it. He says,
then she will follow it up with,
why don't you listen to the
radio or another podcast
and down the rabbit hole it
goes, oh, I don't like this
person already. The thing is,
these questions are
nonstop and so subjective.
It got to the point where I straight up
asked her if she was trolling me and she
denied it. Everything else in
relationship is going well,
so I'm not sure what to do.
I've talked to her and told her
she asked too many questions.
She then turns around on me and says,
I never want to talk to her. Any.
Oh, she turns it,
turns it around on me and says that
I never want to talk to her anymore.
That's not talking. It's just asking
a bunch of fucking question. She'll,
what should I do? Break up with
her. Just answered the questions.
What would you do, Bill? Why is your
name bill anyways? Why not, Dave? Huh?
Why isn't it Dave? Bill, why
aren't you answering me? Bill?
Don't want to talk anymore. Why is the
podcast an hour anyways? Why not an hour,
10 or 50 minutes? Hot
Bill. Yeah. All right dude,
I just walked in your shoes
there. Yeah. Uh, yeah. I, I,
I would break up with her.
I'd break up with them.
Um, I maybe a, but if you really like her,
I give her one last
chance and just be like,
just tell it you're driving
me fucking insane. And um,
yeah, it just, you're driving me fucking
insane. I like everything about you,
but that, and if my life with you is
going to be that, I'm going to leave.
Okay. Um, but I gotta be honest with dude,
I don't know how people
change. Changing yourself,
who the fuck you are is really difficult,
so hopefully it'll work out with you.
So that's, that's what I would
do. I would just say, listen,
I like everything but that everything
about you is great except for that.
But that is so fucking horrific.
This is going to walk out that
fucking door if you don't cut it up.
That's it. That's it. If I
could redo my whole dating life,
it would have been fucking communicating
instead of just being like, Woo,
fuck. And then gone out and getting
shit faced. What was wrong with USA?
No thing. I'm sorry. And then you
don't fucking work it out. Hey,
we're going out. Okay. All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves. I'll
check it on Thursday.
A thank you to everybody
who's been listening to the
podcast and I'm obviously,
I am beyond excited to do
this tour. Um, starting, uh,
oh my God, the 31st no, it
starts the 30th doesn't it?
The Fuck Outta here?
Yeah.
Oh, my show wasn't until the
31st well, what do you know?
I'll have an extra day there
and [inaudible]. All right,
here it is in case you're listening.
Dublin, Ireland, Belfast and Gallway.
Then Bristol, UK,
Manchester, UK. All right. I,
you probably should say the
dates. July 31st I'm in Dublin.
August 1st I'm in Belfast August
2nd Gallway then I go over to,
uh, England.
I'm in Bristol on the third and
on the fourth I'm in Manchester.
You know what's in between Bristol and
Manchester? John Bottoms, grave site.
If I have time, I'm
going to pay my respects.
I'm not going to do a fucking
Selfie, like a Douche.
A just going to pay my respects
if I have the time. Um,
August 6th, fifth and sixth, I'm
in London, England. August 7th.
I'm in Amsterdam. August 8th. Um,
and I'm in Edinburgh for
two shoes. August 9th.
I'm in Edinburgh. Um,
for two more shows the
fuck doing all right there.
August 11th. No, wait a minute.
Yeah, I did say Amsterdam,
right on August 7th, August
11th, I'm in Cologne,
Germany, and then August
12th, I'm in Antwerp, Belgium.
And then August 27th, I'm in Reno, Nevada,
back in the USA. All right, everybody,
thank you for listening and thank you
to everybody overseas has been dumped,
buying tickets. I can't wait to come
over there and, uh, make you laugh.
All right. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you on Thursday.